opérations de pompage en pleine nuit à
aubigny dans le sous sol de cette maison
les 120 mètres carrés ont été plus
longues et l'eau est montée très
rapidement en un quart d'heure a ouvert
les portes
voilà c'est un touché que que le sous
sol pour vous oui bah et qui seraient
augmentés là où j'avais un statut que
l'école tout selon lui la route était
inondé partout au parc partout les
pompiers sont à pied d'oeuvre ils sont
même venus des casernes voisines pour
prêter main forte
la nuit dernière il ya eu une
quarantaine d'interventions sur le
secteur nord du cher peu habitué à ces
intempéries
il est tombé énormément d'eau en très
peu de temps quoi donc et en plus avec
des sous sols comme il y en a par ici ça
remplit twitter un peu plus loin aux
abords de la piscine des étangs la route
et les fossés sont inondées toute la
machinerie de la piscine située à un
étage en dessous et sous l'eau la maire
d'aubigny est venu constater les dégâts
l'opération de pompage prendra du temps
je crois que demain elle va rester
fermée on nous allons essayer de la
remettre en route demain matin pour voir
mais on va y aller doucement braqué deux
qu'il n'y ait pas de casse un bien
entendu et puis on verra si lundi on
peut la réouvrir ce sac l'orage n'a pas
épargné la petite église de concressault
30 centimètres d'eau dans les travées
l'eau s'est infiltrée par la porte un
petit cours d'eau a débordé a dévalé la
rue du village cet habitant n'a pas eu
le temps de protéger ses meubles
il a assisté impuissants à la montée des
eaux les montrent au moins de deux
mètres
c'est la première fois que ça vous
arrive au nouveau si oui en fait quatre
cinq ans qu'on est là ça avait il ya
vingt ans je crois et à votre avis c'est
dû à quoi
la buse qui est trop petit c'était
vraiment trop petite la bus qui passent
sous le soul sur la route et le fait
qu'on est dans une cuvette on récolte
toutes les eaux pluviales de toutes les
maisons et des ruissellements deschamps
des routes quoi certains n'étaient pas
chez eux au moment du déluge
cet épisode orageux n'a pas fait de
victime mais des dégâts matériels
importants